we're going to meet up with an old old
friend of mine who is now a successful
restaurateur here in Los Angeles Chris
has alerted us to some of the hottest
pad tight spots in the city pad tight or
yeah we're on a pad tight or your food
is very different than like standard
American Thai food so like what what is
it about it that's different what have
you done differently the only goal I
really have with the food is to make it
as delicious as possible 90% of the time
that amounts to making it start of the
most traditional way it's been boiled
down to just like the essence there are
certain things about the process that
I'll do different because I think it
makes a better end product there like
this was a big order in which you put
spices together that can alter the
intensity as opposed to just having it
just like too much of something I don't
usually try to get too technical with
you know our food and what we do but I
would break down pot I into like four or
five things technique you know meaning
like how you work the ingredients in the
wok the seasoning the quality of the
noodles is it too soft is it chewy the
fourth thing is just like how amped it
is it's supposed to have this kind of
trifecta of like kind of tart kind of
salty and kind of sweet but where it's
all in balance I'm hungry now
like I'm straight-up hungry can we
follow you into the kitchen yeah let's
do it
[Applause]
we're gonna make the most basic kind of
elemental no-frills pot I guess who gets
the basic one ready
of course oh yeah throw in the noodles
and then we put in this is basically
tofu and sweet radish this is
essentially like a basic cut time now
we're gonna do one that's sort of not as
basic it's a little more decadent what
should we call this the Mandy Moore and
I think for this one we can step it up
to Brittany you guys want to go try this
if I'm just ordering pad thai to get a
feel for the restaurant this is how I
want it pad thai has always been like a
Chinese restaurant serves it because
people demand it so much but then I
order that and it's like super mushy and
wet this kind of web app tile that's not
a good look if it's sort of smoky and
the noodles are cooked but kind of chewy
still then I've done my job
come on when you eat food it both makes
it look appetizing and very appetizing I
don't know how you do it it's like that
thing you know like dance like no one's
watching or whatever it's like eat like
no one's watching so with the Brittany
you know you want to get some of the
eggy part you want to get some shrimp
that Brittany though that's amped up I
like both but I think I like the Mandy
you're feeling Steven do
today we'll base it this is our
pictorial calm Ileana
that basically means like grilled pig
neck Wow
oh that's intended yeah I brought out
this beer because the other component to
this dish is essentially the drinks that
goes with it so we're gonna go check out
some other toy restaurants that Chris
enjoys I think what we should do at each
restaurant is get their Pad Thai and
then also get like a specialty item off
their menu that is there like thing that
you think is really awesome at that spot
let's go to uh lash awesome thumbs the
papaya salad place so we're headed to
Thai town one of my favorite places in
LA get down
Chris has just informed me that he gets
carsick really easily
we had the Mandy in the Britney hey so
we're on the search for the lady got
back let's do it yeah I'm pretty
confident we can find a lady gaga let's
take it alright that's pretty oh it's so
different from your fad diet
I do like of Chris's noodles better I
can see that the meat is super crystal
super crispy I kind of like that better
now Chris this makes you what I call the
paparazzi or are you crazy in love I
think we should taste the other one
first and really and then judge we've
only been here for like five minutes by
the way
look at this we need to emphasize that
over and over again colin is a monster
on a sailboat so this is the
oh man that crab omelet Wow
it's like so many different flavors
really coming together coming love with
a crab papaya salad coming up what that
is not what I was expecting either I'm
going all fingers they're basically
french fries onion rings vibe but it's
less heavy oh yeah this is a version
with marinated raw blue crab we
basically just suck the meat and like
the juice out of it how you grab all the
time I've never had raw crab it's a
totally different experience usually
view a cooked crab you gotta like pick
it out needed this is just like coming
out at me I feel like an animal eating
this and it feels so good that crab
omelet one was beyond that she is like
super iconic and it gives me just more
like that comfort feeling as opposed to
like super crazy out there I think we
found our Gaga or Beyonce I'm not asleep
yet I'm just getting sleepy the sleep
cam oh man I get caught sleep in every
video pad Titus we're here at the last
stop this is piling we're gonna have a
tie and we're gonna have coastal which
is curry noodles oh yeah this looks
really promising who was it Freddy I
want to say Sierra it's got to move it's
got the moves
it's a Mariah to me you know like it's
full of Flair but like also knows the
basic truly well I didn't know that I
could have so many different styles to
try those rules yo I've been looking I
in this guy in the beginning
this is my favorite thing that's so good
doesn't this seem like something you'd
eat like I'm like a cold wintry night
are you eating off your lap maybe I'm
gonna explode right now yeah he was
saying that I we gotta try the northern
sausage and I already ordered it so
hopefully it'll come out in a quick
second
I think my something just made room got
some crazy sausage that's a great way to
end the day are here thank you Chris for
having us
Thai food is more than Pad Thai I
already knew that but now it's gonna
reinforce my mind is an expanded
I know like to go to than what they get
I think I'm realizing now that I was
like very ignorant with Thai food in the
Thai like anything Thai related
I just got taken to school by Chris
today peace I can't pull it off
[Music]